[Música]
antes de te conhecer
eu já conhecia o samba sempre nas
rodadas de bamba também aprendi a ver só
antes de te conhecer
eu já estava apaixonada pelo som da
batucada nem complicar mudar depois que
te conheci minha vida ficou diferente
o amor nasceu em mim sendo assim eu
venho é contente
hoje saiu bem menos que antes
ainda assim sou feliz do jeito que eu
queria
você insatisfeito reclama dessa negra
que te ama sua proposta é covardia não
me pede pra escolher
entre o samba e você entre o amor ea
madrugada sem saída eu vou ficar sem
você não tenho paz em samba não dá mais
minha vida não é nada vamos conciliar
depois que te conheci minha vida ficou
diferente do amor nasceu em mim sendo
assim o bem mais potente
hoje saiu bem menos que antes
ainda assim sou feliz do jeito que eu
queria
você insatisfeito reclama dessa negra
tinham
só proposta de covardia não me pede pra
escolher
entre o samba e você entre amor é a
madrugada sem saída eu vou ficar sem
você não tenho pai soma no amar minha
vida lula não vamos conciliar não me
pede não me pede pra escolher
entre o samba e você entre o amor é a
madrugada sem sair eu vou ficar sem você
não tem no pa
a extensa mas não dá voz a minha vida
não é nada vamos conciliar
[Música]
ai ai ai ai ai
a ai ai ai ó minha vida não é nada vamos
conciliar
[Música]
[Aplausos]